all right let's head back to gail in van
horn texas for more coverage
of blue origins launch sun is up there
gail skye's looking good
i know the sky's looking good i mean the
weather seems pretty perfect to me
jeff bezos and his fellow passengers are
now on new shepard we saw them get on
about 10 minutes ago
they were walking up a ramp and before
they walked in they each rang a little
bell i'm not quite sure exactly what
that means
we were looking at the feed from the
training center and we saw
mark bezos helping his brother jeff do
something with his
his flight suit it's very cute it's a
very intimate moment when you see the
four of them together
just sitting there waiting former nasa
astronaut peggy whitson knows
just what those moments feel like she
has spent more
cumulative time in space than any other
american
and the most of any woman in the world
685 days in total
during her time at nasa she was
commander of the international space
station
twice you go ms whitson now she plans to
come out of retirement
and travel to space again as commander
for the private company
axiom space peggy whitson joins us now
good morning to you peggy whitson
you know a few minutes ago they put a
pause on the countdown clock
it only lasted for four minutes they
don't have to tell us a reason
but when you hear that there's a pause
what does that say to you and what
what does that do to you mentally when
there's a pause
it's back it's counting again so
everything seems to be fine but there
was a four-minute pause
well for shuttle launches we always had
built-in holds i don't know that they do
that
for uh for blue but in any case they are
not going to a destination so it'll be
okay
they're they're going just to space and
as long as they
are satisfied that whatever issue is
resolved they'll be
fine but everything on launch day is a
hurry up and wait kind of thing you have
to hurry up to be on time
then you have to wait and so it's it's a
little disconcerting
being at mode
yeah you know wonder peggy i got up at
three o'clock this morning and one of
the first things i started thinking
about
was the bezos brothers and the other two
crew members
what this must feel like to them this
waiting i don't i was thinking
do you sleep the night before what do
you eat the night before
are you nervous as you're sitting there
just waiting to go
tell us what that was like for you and
what you think they must be feeling at
this moment
well on my very first lunch i was very
worried about
uh doing everything right um there's
is a lot more relaxed in the sense that
they don't have to do a lot of complex
maneuvers but they have only a very
short period of time while they're in
space
and so they're going to want to take
advantage of every second while they're
up there so they're probably thinking
about i'm going to do this first and
then i'm going to do this
and you know figure out their sequence
of events
you know a lot has been a lot of there's
we were talking about the training what
goes into this as you said
they don't have to do a lot of complex
maneuvers basically all they have to do
is get in there and ride
and when you talk about the training uh
in the book it says
anybody in reasonable health could do
this some of the requirements are this
height and weight range 510 110
110 pounds six four up to 223 pounds
be able to dress yourself in a one piece
zip up flight suit
uh be able to strap and unstrap in 15
seconds
and remain strapped into a crew capsule
for 40 minutes and up to 90 minutes
and not have to use the bathroom or get
up so the training is very very
different from when you were training
can you just give us a glimpse into what
your training was like back in the day
compared to
and these as we know very two different
types of flights
it is extremely different because we
trained two years just
basic training learning all the systems
of the
space shuttle and the international
space station
and then later i learned soyuz systems
as well but for each flight then there
was a couple of more years of training
so it's it's a much more complex
uh and covers a much bigger period
yeah can you also talk about a lot has
been made of richard branson just went
up elon musk
spacex vehicle went up and now we've got
blue origin you know i've heard it
described as joyride for billionaires
maybe it's a vanity project when you
talk to all three of these men
they also they emphasize nothing could
be further from the truth
they feel very committed to this cause
very passionate about it
how do you see what they're doing well i
think it's really
important what we what we're seeing now
these are the first steps
of commercial space flight and uh
commercialization of space in particular
which i think
you know is it has to be built in these
piece parts and so
yes it takes money to make some of these
things happen and
uh it's a very very exciting time
because not only do we have blue
and uh virgin doing sub-orbital flights
we're gonna have later this year
uh inspiration four on spacex and then
next year we'll have
a couple of axiom flights to the
international space station so
it's all building blocks that
allow commercialization of space and the
utilization of space for commercial
purposes
and i think you're going to see some
really exciting developments in the next
few years
just based on the commercial
i feel it here and i got to say peggy i
got a big old girl crush on wally funk i
know
that you've met her you know her people
say she's a real deal in one sentence
how would you describe her
uh infectious enthusiasm
and extremely effervescent
she is she's everything yes you know
well done your ambassador to space to me
yes absolutely right liz you know she's
82 and she told us yesterday she feels
24.
i want some of what she's drinking thank
you peggy whitson it's always good to
see you
thank you very much